this story ended up being more
complicated than I thought it is
generally accepted that the oldest
business in the world the oldest that's
still operating anyway is the nishiyama
Onsen keonka which is this hot springs
hotel about three hours West of Tokyo
for more than 1 300 years people have
been coming here for the natural crystal
clear hot water baths and until recently
the owners have been 52 generations of
the same family
foreign
there are other people staying here
tonight by the way it's just we're not
filming them for obvious privacy reasons
the hotel's not empty anyway I assume
that I'd be staying in something like a
Living Museum here because that's what
I've come to expect from the sort of
historical attractions you'll find in
Britain that's what tends to happen to
anything centuries old where I'm from a
kind of preservation that means that
everything must be held at a certain
point in time funded by tourists who
want to visit the old thing and see
history which is great if you're running
a museum but for a hotel business that
needs to survive in the 21st century
well customers will change with the
times
foreign
[Music]
there's still tradition here it's not a
western style Hotel you sleep on futons
didn't reserved a low Japanese style
table but this place has been updated
again and again and again this building
is only a few decades old the exact
location has moved around this area many
times over the years it's only been a
hotel in the English sense for a few
decades before that it was just a place
to stay and take the waters now there's
very fast Wi-Fi and of course a gift
shop they excavated new Hot Springs in
2005 which gave them five times as much
hot water another modern pumps and
systems to check water temperature and
quality the water's drinkable by the way
it's a hot spring after all it's mineral
water
so that was going to be the story this
is the world's oldest business because
it changes with the times
problem one with that the Modern English
language concept of business doesn't
quite map correctly onto Japanese
culture from more than a millennium ago
obviously there is a school of flower
arrangement in Kyoto called ikonobo that
was founded a couple of centuries before
this but that school probably counts as
an organization in English rather than
business as best as I can tell from
translations from a local team here if
you do count that school you kind of
have to count much older things like the
Catholic Church as well this has always
been a definite business so problem two
this has only been the oldest business
in the world since 2006 when the former
record holder a construction company
called Congo Gumi fell on hard times but
Conga Gumi didn't close or go bankrupt
it was bought by a bigger Construction
Company it had been a family business
for nearly 1500 years but now it's just
a subsidiary of a modern company still
operating but arguably just a name on an
organization chart
should Congo Gumi still count I don't
think so
but if it doesn't count that brings me
to problem three with this story which
all the English-speaking sources I found
seem to have missed it
is
[Music]
there was no practical change to what
was happening here that seems more like
a restructure than a takeover the new
owner is the old general manager so
while it's not in the family there is
continuity and I hate to say I'm not
sure but if there's been one theme
through this channel over the years I've
been making videos it's that the world
is complicated and it doesn't fit in
neat little categories if you've got a
list like oldest businesses that is a
millennium and a half old
of course it's gonna have a few
asterisks in it
as for me
I'm just gonna go and take the waters
[Music]
foreign